hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga and today it's time for more
of my ever beloved Hunter hunter and
quite specifically we are going to delve
into the question of who will win the
succession war now if you are not on top
of the succession more as it currently
stands look I don't blame you because it
has been almost a year since a new
chapter has been published and even if
you were completely up-to-date it's a
pretty dense art class far but I do have
a quick succession will recap available
which briefly covers all of Prince's
monks other things and that might give
you some good preparation for this video
because our task today is to examine who
has the best chance of actually coming
out on top and to do this we'll be
examining the princess by Tears
beginning with who I believe have no
chance of winning whatsoever followed by
those with you know a maybe chance of
winning and finally we'll cover the
cream of the crop with the frontrunners
to take this entire contest now to begin
let's actually address an even lower
tier which are the princes who barring
some sort of incredible Resurrection NB
s have already been removed from the
running due to their unfortunate and
gruesome demise Prince's that fall into
this category are 12th Prince momma's
heir who was brutally strangled by an
assailant after she had become exhausted
invoking the powers of her nan beast
shortly after 10th prince Cacho met her
end by attempting to escape from the
battlegrounds although the exact nature
for her death is still rather mysterious
I guess it has something to do with lots
of scary hands and such by the way she's
gone well sort of I mean her nan beast
is currently impersonating her but we're
not going to be considering that and
finally 8th Prince Alice Allah was
assassinated by one of first Prince
Benjamin's bodyguards and the way his
corpse was found very much mimics the
way Silas Allah chose to live which was
entirely naked in a pool of his own
filth but that's it for that these are
the three princes that are definitely
not going to win may they rest in peace
or if they were particularly awful
people in may they rest in torment or
whatever moving on though I would like
to now present you with the four princes
who are highly unlikely to win which are
mariam to pepper
tyson and forget sue starting with xiii
prince mariam this little guy is in a
pretty rough spot he is both a child and
one of the lowest ranking princes within
the empire meaning that he does not
possess the personal strength experience
or resources to be a proper competing
force in the war he does have a couple
of decent factors going for him of
course one of which is obviously an n
beast although every other parens also
has an n beast so that would cancel that
factor out at best and in fact
worst Mariama is probably even at a
great disadvantage because of it because
the other older princes would likely be
wilting their beast powers in much more
efficient ways than he is able to but
Miriam does also have both Biscay and
Hanzo currently serving as his
bodyguards and that certainly is not
power to scoff at they're both
incredibly profound figures within the
hunt underworld but I don't think
they're enough to keep Miriam safe at
all costs so to be honest all of the
remaining princes
I think Miriam is in the worst possible
situation and while killing children you
know it's pretty dark it's certainly not
beyond Takashi to invoke Plus even in a
situation where the war ends and Miriam
is somehow magically alive he is not
going to be the winner and look maybe
this will be the biggest plot twist in
history and I'm going to look like quite
the fool 10 decades down the road when
the sock finally concludes but as of
right now I'm sorry my boy
but you've got no chance similarly I
honestly don't think the fifth Prince to
Peppa has a great chance of winning here
now I do want to be clear she has a
better chance than Miriam but at the
same time I think all of the remaining
princes do so that doesn't mean too much
the main thing that really worries me
about Tibet is that her NIMBY seems like
a very squishy existence like it does
seem to contain some very nice power in
regards to synthesizing various
compounds which to bepah is in a great
position to wield being a science
goddess in all however her beast is also
very very timid which on the one hand is
great because it would signify that the
Beast is very careful but it also likely
implies that if the beast was caught in
a singular bad situation and it would be
very unlikely to come out of said
situation in a good way by which I mean
it's a goner
now some evidence that may be in her
favor is that she appears to have made a
temporary alliance with 4th Prince
erratic but I honestly believe that that
makes her situation far far worse
because that man is not to be trusted
under any circumstances and even if he
could be trusted in this specific
situation
allowing sir I'd Nick to outlive the
first three princes were practically in
short to Peppa's death anyway because
with them gone there is going to be
almost nobody who could stand in his way
so to Peppa's path to victory is an
extremely cautious one she is a
contender who cannot afford to make a
single mistake and as intelligent as she
is there are too many variables at play
here with eleven other princes each
plotting and scheming for absolutely no
mistakes to be made and that makes a
beast and therefore her highly highly
vulnerable going down the line we have
the immediate consecutive Prince being
six Prince Tyson now ty
has an incredibly powerful nan beast
that has essentially turned her into a
cult leader who dreams of reshaping the
world in her own image so Tyson's an
invisibility kind of follows Alice Alice
in that it essentially converts people
into thinking of her favorably well
they've IRA a completely different
mechanism and you know that didn't work
out very well for Sally Sally being dead
and all but I do have to say that Tyson
is a much more proficient wielder of the
power the big issue is that Tyson unlike
most cult leaders seems to genuinely
believe her own words that love can
change the world and that she will
oppose any form of violent action now
that obviously means that Tyson's
chances of winning become much more
difficult because it would take an
absolutely incredible series of lucky
events for her to win by doing nothing
and yeah I know she's not strictly
speaking doing nothing she is converting
people and building a legion but she is
still a passive player and I just can't
see her finding a path to victory in
this field of contenders and finally for
the incredibly unlikely to win tier we
have xi prince forget su now I will
start off by saying that forgets who has
unknowingly inherited quite an
incredible power and essentially has
tune in beasts on her side at the moment
one of which is the door and the other
which is the late 10th Prince Koch O's
beast which has assumed her form and
this is very important because forgets
whose beast can only be fully utilized
in concert with Cacho and what it does
is it basically allows them to travel
anywhere they want within the bounds of
the battlefield so of all the contenders
in this tier forgets who is definitely
the one who is going to be by far the
hardest to actually kill because her
mobility is second to none however the
problem is that forgets who is more or
less a normal teenage girl very kind
very timid and very soft-hearted
she has no place in this contest all she
can really do is run until either she or
catches an end beast gets caught not who
I'd be putting my money on because like
Tyson there would need to be an
incomparable series of lucky events for
foo get sue to win whilst doing nothing
but hiding but with that tier out of the
way we can move on to the next batch of
candidates which actually have a chance
of winning not the best chance in my
mind but a chance nonetheless and they
consist of Zhang Li losers Camila and
Benjamin now 3rd Prince angley is in
quite an interesting spot I would
definitely say that he's probably not in
anybody's personal legitimate favourites
to win and I definitely questioned his
ability to remain in this wall for the
long run and my main reason for thinking
that he has a maybe not so great chance
of coming out of this victoriously as
entirely to do with his nen beast and
while we don't know anything except
speculation regarding it at this very
moment speculation in Hunt Honda can be
incredibly influential because the beast
is modeled after Zhang Lee's thoughts
personality desires essentially
everything that makes him him so when
Zhang lei speculates about a beast
modeled after himself well then that all
of a sudden becomes pretty meaningful
and Zhang leis current theory is that
the power of his nan beast will kick
into true gear after the war has ended
and he's had the opportunity to spread
the coins it generates throughout his
kingdom which is super cool and all but
if that is the case then it's going to
be less than helpful in a war with some
pretty insane enemies powers that he'll
be going up against however in Zhang
leis defense he does have the resources
and intelligence to do quite well
especially since he has an alliance with
one of the three great mafia powers of
the cocoon underworld and that is what
keeps him in the maybe tier the fact
that he does have manpower and the
wisdom to put it to good use so even in
the situation where his nan beast is
entirely useless during the contest
which I don't think it will be but let's
say that it is for argument's sake I
can't deny that he could still
potentially maybe pull this off next up
is 7th Prince losers and this made
gunner a weird response at first because
it really doesn't seem like he should be
up here with the first three princes of
the car cane Empire however there is
almost certainly a hell of a lot more
than meets the eye with this man so just
like Zhang Li Lu xerus is also a
benefactor of one of the three great
mafia powers within the cocoon
underworld and that should not be
underestimated because one man power is
always great and two because it sure is
a very shady and deceptive side to loser
Asst that has not been made apparent in
any of his appearances thus far to add
to this loser ass as an NB seemed to be
entirely based on the concept of
deception and is able to conjure
whatever a person desires to lure them
into a trap of some sort so I would
honestly put losers in a similar role as
Zhang lay intelligent and powerful and
[ __ ] on to that loser er certainly has
an end beast that can actually help in
the contest so if left unchecked
I think losers could present quite a
danger to the others not enough to be
considered a front-runner but definitely
enough to be a dark horse moving along
we have second Prince Camilla and this
might shock some of you to have her
being so far down in the rankings
because she does seem to have an
exceptional combination of power to
begin Camilla is already an end-user and
has even developed her in hot sue which
takes the form of a big ol kitty cat
that absorbs a life force of those that
kill Camilla and to add to that her
guardian n beast has the power
to take control of people so this right
here is a potentially overpowered
combination in the Camila could
theoretically force people to kill her
and then have them die instead of her
what I find tricky about Camila though
is that death is an activation
requirement for her heart sir so for
argument's sake well you'd really need
to do to defeat Camila is keep her alive
but maybe heavily injured or sedated I
also think that such a powerful ability
is bound to come with more restrictions
or conditions that haven't been
literally conveyed to us yet for example
and has been implied that Camila may
need to be in a state of zetsu upon her
death in order for her heart so to
activate in which case you would not be
able to have her nan beast materialized
which takes away the idea of her
controlling people
but another factor is that Camila also
doesn't seem very keen to be using her
guardian Beast in the first place and it
would appear that she is putting all of
her stock into her existing nen talents
which is kind of arrogant and she's also
very very aggressive in terms of putting
herself in danger due to the safety net
that she believes her hot sue is so all
in all Camila seems like a very risky
individual and her abilities and
personality a kind of ill fitting for a
contest like this and now we have first
Prince Benjamin who is quite possibly
one of the most threatening singular
individuals in the entire rock in terms
of everything to do with raw power this
guy has it and just like Camila he comes
into this war as an end user with
another pretty crazy ability known as
Benjamin baton and essentially with this
Benjamin is able to inherit the nen
abilities of soldiers who are part of
his private army and as of right now he
is the proud user of three separate in
abilities as a result now at the moment
we're not clear on whether or not there
is a limit to the number of hot two that
can come under his command but even if
there is and even if that limit is quite
low this is still pretty insane because
gives him a whole range of versatility
before his own guardian beast even comes
into the mix Plus as stated before he
has control of his own private army so
in terms of pure power this is the guy
to beat and I think that he will be a
serious and destructive force going
forward my issue with Benjamin is that I
don't think that he is well placed
mentally to become the true victor of
this war I mean yes he is a shot
military tactician but he is
exceptionally and easily moved to anger
and aggression and I believe that a man
like him could be quite easily played by
any about three remaining candidates
speaking of we're finally here these are
the three princes that I believe have
nothing short of a spectacular chance of
winning this contest and becoming the
next case
of the cocking Empire and those three
princes are Hawken burg
sir I'd Nick and just stay with me here
wobble starting with ninth Prince
Hulkenberg though in him we have a true
revolutionary and an honourable human
being initially he entered the war with
a pacifist attitude refusing to commit
bloodshed and if that was still the case
then I certainly would not be placing
him in this tier but as time went on
Holcomb Berg's resolv'd became firm to
the point but he was even willing to
kill his own father in order to stop the
succession war and later on he even
committed himself to winning the contest
in the hopes of forever changing the car
cane Empire now halkan Burke's inner
strength I would say is unequaled
amongst the entirety of the [ __ ] in
royalty and that is reflected in his nan
beast which not only makes Holcomb Berg
more powerful but also his loyal
followers thus putting him in a position
to muster a truly incomparable force and
in fact it has already been speculated
that Holcomb bugs newly acquired power
could potentially wipe out first Prince
Benjamin's entire faction which is a
pretty big call to make but it was made
by one of the soldiers of Benjamin's own
army so I do trust that judgment but
Hawken Berg is a true contender because
he is a pure believer kind of like Tyson
except that Holcomb Burke inspires his
loyalty naturally but also he has the
will to actually fight for the future
that he believes in weirdly enough
Falkenberg has a poor relationship with
his entire family except for 4th prince
or idak
and I find that incredibly strange
because the to adjust such polar
opposites in terms of personality but
this positive relationship may be halkan
bugs one major weakness because if he
hesitates even for a second when
confronting sorry I'd Nick then that
could very easily spell his doom
speaking of let's examine 4th Prince
ironic and I think if you took a poll of
favourites to win this contest
he'd quite comfortably come out on top
and for very good reason because he's
one of the most gifted individuals that
Honda Honda has ever produced with a
rapidly growing and downright sinister
mastery of NIM and just for one example
of that so right Nick is the kind of man
who is capable of subconsciously
summoning a second and Beast which is
ridiculous but he has also developed a
heart su that in a rather complicated
manner gives him access to a former
Future Sight not only that but Sir I'd
Nick is more than intelligent enough to
wield that power to great effect making
him by far the most dangerous individual
in the contest from a perspective of men
but sad Nick like his two brothers is
also a mafia benefactor and so commands
a very sizeable under both power and you
know while sir I'd Nick might not have
shir drive to win that Hawken burg has
he does possess the lust to soar to his
siblings which is also a very compelling
force to be feared and all in all I
don't see any weaknesses for sir I'd
Nick right now in terms of personality
or power
there's just no opening and to be
perfectly frank every second that this
man is allowed to live makes him an
infinitely more difficult obstacle to
overcome a very strong contender indeed
and finally for our top tier candidates
may I present 14th Prince woogle so you
might be thinking that wobble does not
belong here or indeed anywhere near here
I mean she is a baby she has the least
resources available for her of any of
the princes and as far as we are aware
her nan beast has not even manifested
yet sounds like wells in a pretty bad
situation the thing is though Roble has
something going for her that could
single-handedly decide the outcome of
this entire war and that is karateka
this man is far more valuable than any
nan beast or hot suit crop ACCA's
intelligence is through the roof in fact
he may well be one of the smartest
characters in this entire world and he
can back that up with phenomenal nan
usage as a natural conjurer with the
option to become a specialist I
wholeheartedly believe that crop ago
could do anything that he sets his mind
to and if that job is to protect verbal
and that's what's going to happen and
really if anybody can overcome the
natural genius of surat Nik it's
definitely karateka and furthermore
krupka also has a vendetta against her I
Nick as he is the owner of the last
remaining batch of scarlet eyes which
means that our blonde protagonist is
going to have his sights set on taking
out the prime candidate to win and
remember what I said earlier whatever
crop occur says his mine too well it's
as good as done that and that alone is
why I believe that wobble is a prime
candidate to win the succession war and
that pretty much does it for this
discussion on who will win the
succession war if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produce in
general and please do consider donating
to the New World review patreon because
the support of all of your amazing
people is what continues to make this
channel possible and if patreon isn't
quite your style then please do leave
this video a like share or subscribe
because it also helps for this channel
an incredible amount and if you'd like
to join the fun at any time then please
do head over tomatoe scores over for a
wide array of shenanigan retakes place
on a daily basis and finally please do
comment with your thoughts on who will
win the six
this has been the new old review and
I'll see you next time
[Music]